so yeah uh as just said welcome to the
data science skills that you already on
uh in this byata impact um this is the
agenda for today so I'm going to give
you a bit of my background um hopefully
you will find it relevant to to what I'm
trying to show and then the motivation
and inspiration to to create such a talk
or a workshop of this one and then I
will dive a bit in some case studies
these are not uh you know real case
studies or real situations that happen
but they are inspired on on real
situations that happened H and uh I
would like to look at them in the
perspective of learning from them and
trying to take some some from it so uh
then the idea is to give the the
participants uh some time to to look at
their own skills and uh apply the what
uh we just talked about uh in a very
short questionnaire and um and I will
explain more about it afterwards I'm
planning a bit of a break after this
just to give people to to work on it and
then of course uh we closed um this
Workshop so starting on my background uh
as just said my background is on
molecular biology I did the BC in
genetics and msse in Biochemistry and
then I started yet not finish a PhD in
Health
Sciences and throughout that time I did
a research always in the topic of of
molecular biology with different types
of of data um after that uh I join the
the currently where I still work on uh
it's called jumia is an e-commerce
platform that is focused on the the
African Market um and of course
everything that I say today here is not
related with my employers is uh my
perspectives and my
own and basically uh talk a bit about me
I I I program in in Python since pretty
much my my PhD years in my PhD years I
starting uh developing the the data
stack that you normally see around
python today uh with all the the python
tools also SQL and then um and stuff
like flash a bit and um and then uh
programming in Python doing data
analysis data preparation and even a bit
of machine learning and then of course
when I started as a data scientist uh I
developed more the the machine learning
part and that's pretty much uh where I'm
at um why I find this relevant for you
that probably listening to this because
I'm not that senior but at the same time
I don't consider myself in an early
career stage right now so I'm somewhere
in between and this may be useful
because I still remember quite well the
early career days so I I still empathize
and and remember the struggles of it uh
and maybe I have something to to give to
to
others that are in a more early career
stage I'm Portuguese I currently live in
in Portugal as you can see here from my
L LinkedIn in Port um and uh if you have
any questions uh during during this
session please interrupt me English is
not my main language so if you want to
you know if you didn't understand
something please tell me to to explain
it in other words I will not be offended
at
all so let's start about motivation so
why doing the this talk uh so I want
here to to a community a Portuguese
community of data scientists called data
science Portugal and we had an event
where I was the moderator of a round
table a discussion table about early
career in data science it was very
recently and I had my plan as a
moderator you know my script focused on
uh trying to steer a bit uh the
discussion away from the normal skills
that are spoke about like you know
python
SQL uh uh machine learning math those
type of things and focusing more on the
remainder of the job and actually I
didn't T to do it because the speakers
um from GetGo started immediately going
in these directions which was um very uh
very insuring for me um that knowing
that the other people are were also
focusing on this type of ideas and
overall for me it's it's really painful
really heartbreaking looking back to
people that are in early stages career
like I was some years ago and seeing
that they cannot um see the value that
uh they have and the skills that they
have um and they are not able to
recognize it and suffer a lot with
stress with sadness of of fearing that
they are not good enough or they are not
capable of enough so hopefully uh with
this type of of of conversations uh we
start having um some more knowledge in
the in these ideas and be and talk about
this more freely and hopefully help out
uh people in early stage
career so let's jump in uh into the the
the case studies again mock cases that I
created from nowhere however they are
still inspired in some some real life
events so the first case is a molecular
biology student why because as you know
by now uh I was a molecular biology
student and this is actually something
very similar to to things that happen
imagine this is a conversation and the
student goes like there are no job jobs
asking for my skills and I'm like really
what skills are you talking about and
the student goes a beautiful sentence
like this I'm really good doing Western
blots and my success rate of cell
cultural uh viral transection was
complemented by my advisor if you are
not from molecular biology this sentence
probably didn't make sense to you which
is completely fine um what I'm trying to
to demonstrate here is that
this student is develop really good
skills of doing some tasks that are very
very specific for this field even within
the field are very very specific for
what the student is doing and um in this
case this student is proposing himself
as as like these are their main their
main skills so my question is are these
really the stupid skills and uh by the
way uh if you are in this call and you
want to to interact uh please feel free
to to use the chat actually let me open
the chat back now because I I just
closed it and feel free to to to to
interact by text or if you want to to
speak please unmute yourself and and
just answer if I make a question to the
audience H it's perfectly fine if you
take your time to to answer or um if you
know that awkward sounds of um
of video calls we are now we are by now
all used to That Awkward s between a
question and an answer so yeah let's
completely forget about that awkwardness
let's say and just feel free to to
participate oops sorry and then going
back to my presentation are these the
student skills again if you want to
participate feel free to to to sh in I
mean these are things that that student
does again very very narrow very very
specific to the field but are these the
student skills I think that that's the
the main point is this are some of these
skills and not
all so what skills I think the student
is demonstrating in a even in a message
like that that's very specific for for
molecular biology fi uh with the the
type of mindset uh shift that I'm trying
to to convey here in this presentation
what I'm trying to to demonstrate is
that when I look to a message like that
and because I'm from the molecular
biology field so I have some experience
in that area I can um
understand first that the student must
have a really good skill of planning and
project managing because you know that's
an entire pipeline of work you know
going from cell cultures to planning
everything Rel to to cell culture and
doing the transaction
blah blah blah blah blah blah it's a
huge project a huge experiment
so there it is a really uh in demand uh
skill really important for every job
pretty much that the student just
demonstrated and most likely as which is
planning and project
managing then one thing that I love when
we talk about you know not only biology
but physics and pretty much a lot of
topics uh related to Stem and not only
but specifically in stem that people in
these fields that come out of straight
out of college out of college in these
fields are like able to deal with very
complex topics and this is a really
really underestimated skill because you
know job day by day is not that easy and
most likely if um there are questions to
solve problems to solve things to do
most likely if especially if you talk
about big companies or if you go to
create your own business it's a very
complex situation you know you need to
to deal with a lot of moving parts and
that's a great skill that um students
that come from this type of background
demonstrate and it's super translatable
into a data related job because the
projects are normally multiactor
multi-domain with several stakeholders
and several parts several teams working
at the same time so the complexity and
capacity to plan ahead and manage your
own tasks and the project itself it's
super important in the data
field so um keeping up this discussion
about this case scenario um I would like
to in an hypothetical scenario discuss
what skills is the student potentially
not seeing and since the molecular
biology student let's call it
Bob so what skills Bob has that is
potentially not seen again feel free to
to to write in chat or to to to say
something if you are in the call so
being data driven is one of the the
skills that I like to convey the most uh
about people in early
career because being dat driven although
it is at the moment second nature for a
lot of people it's not necessarily the
driven is not second nature to be data
driven for everybody thinking about data
figure how data work uh how you can
build the test but you need to do uh
replications about it and other stuff to
make the the the data really
interesting
um um sorry I'm just looking into the
shot apologies uh it's really uh um
interesting to develop that muscle is
something that make come a second nature
for for a lot of people but others have
to really uh develop them and and uh and
actually work on it to be a useful think
to be really useful for a data uh
related
job curiosity is one thing that I I love
to explore with people because
honestly there's like the world is
really complex but if we are going to to
separate things that are people that are
really good at you know receiving an
order and executing that on that
order and there's other type of people
that you know we have this thing and we
want to make this thing happen or we
have this issue and we want to solve
this issue how do we get from here from
there and honestly if you come from a
background of research this is pretty
pretty much what you do all day it's
like okay how do we go about testing the
hypothesis how we go about creating this
data how we go about testing this
data and this generally is translated in
all pretty much of
St able to talk about complex topics
it's literally um a game changer you can
be really good you know Python
Programming machine learning you name it
if you want not able to talk about the
things that you build the things that
you
create to the stakeholders to the users
whatever it's like it doesn't exist so
you really need to be able to convey uh
complex topics in simple terms or at
least in terms that uh the the majority
of the your audience or your
stakeholders whoever understands and
that's a skill that you can train from
very early on in your in your career
like literally in in college or uh in
your first positions as a internship or
anything like that you have the
opportunity to
communicate plenty of opportunities to
communicate so honestly take those um
and and try to to to use that muscle uh
because it's a really important muscle
um stakeholders uh people in charge um
tend to like people that can can
make them understand what is needed and
why it is
needed uh another thing that is it's a
bit of a b it's the capacity to be at
The Cutting Edge I mean a lot of things
like this but general idea is there's
people that really like to you know
learn one thing and go do that one thing
like let's say it's programming in
JavaScript and go the rest of their life
working on
JavaScript but there are other people
that
um are capable of keeping up on The
Cutting Edge learning new things keep
improving this is a really interesting
skill if you have been
following the field of data in the past
year it it has been completely crazy
with large language models I mean every
single week There's a new
thing uh The Cutting Edge is always
moving further and um
yeah you can choose to be um on the same
thing keep doing what you're doing or um
keep on improving and learning new
stuff so let me just see if there's any
um any comments
here give me a
sec uh I was just sharing on the on the
chat that um maybe you are familiar with
the uh uh yeah this word economic Forum
um they are presenting um the skills of
the future oh thank you yeah exactly as
the skills of the future and you have
you can find the reports on that like
back in the in the like decade or so so
you can see the trend and something
which is very outstanding is like this
analytic thinking creative thinking uh
all that kind of skills and also skills
connected with leadership um uh always
in the ranking are very are very uh high
so it's it's something if you are not
familiar with that that I recommend that
and you can see also how the trend was
going in back in to days but I'm I'm
mentioning that only because it's
definitely something which uh just even
make the Pedro's um message even
stronger you can definitely see the
skills
here thank you very much cila it's
indeed an awesome an awesome some um
infographic and K also link the the post
the the news article for it and I mean I
just talk about this but you can look at
it again some of the things that I just
said that Bob may have as a skill and
not is not even aware of is in the top
skills of 2023 according the world
economic
forum and this is exactly the type of
mindset that I would like people in this
in this uh that listening to this talk
to to Really uh get into uh that
mindset
so then we have a happy happy you know
molecular biology student pop is Happy
the student is without without an head
because you can put every head on the
student you can be even be yourself you
know it's a very deep image so let's
jump into the to the second phase and if
this case um it's actually as well very
similar to an interaction I have to an
engineering
student um and interaction went like uh
it was asking me what online courses do
you recommend me doing I like what would
you like to learn any particular thing
you're interested in working and then I
got absolutely wall of text this wall of
text goes like you know cloud is the
future so I need to to learn the big fre
Cloud
aure I already know python but big data
is the thing right so by spark is a must
um now everybody's talking about gener t
AI so I must learn shat GPT really well
and do prompt engineering and do rag and
do and no Lang chain lamb index and so
for so forth
uh what is the message that I'm trying
to convey here what is the biggest
mistake of these student and actually
here um I'm trying to convey the idea of
two big
mistakes focusing on what he doesn't
does not know this is really big um it's
really important to be able to be here
in the present moment and acknowledge uh
the path that we took to get here and
where we were before and where we are
now sure we should have plans for the
future but being enable to recognize
what we already have today and be
grateful that we already developed those
skills may lead to to to to a lot of
fear and fear is not a good um sentiment
to develop uh to make decisions on and
then another thing that is really
important is that these student focus on
the the skills that you want to
development develop is external driven
Focus please notice that I this
intentionally of course but my question
is what you like to know uh what are you
interested in and the student goes about
like saying what you saw in LinkedIn in
in a post or whatever all of this is
externally focused it's not about what
the person likes and dislikes what you
try and like and is like it's about what
other people are
saying this
is really tough to manage especially if
you are early on on your career because
you see everybody talking everybody
seems to be expert in everything and a
lot of things and
um you feel like you are missing out and
again the sentiment that arises from
this is fear this is the fear
Emoji um and moreover even if this
student uh let's call himine Eugene
Eugene Eugene is the engineering student
uh even if Eugene really puts like
absurd amount of hours while he's
working or doing an internship or
studying and put putting more even more
hours on studyy you know machine
learning math python uh is this
sustainable and the answer is no I mean
life happens um with the with the with
ag we don't get more free time and um
moreover being abolutely in fear is not
a good thing a lot of this is really
summed up in a in an expression called
foro fear of missing out so a lot of
what we see in online platforms um
namely social media is inducing this
because people are showcasing what they
already know and if we don't know that
thing uh it may induce fear of missing
out
so in order to to help you uh better
understand this I'll try I try to create
some visualizations and actually they
are adapted from from this article here
from train etic the link is here on the
bottom so formo looks like this you have
a different subjects and the depth in
the subjects and formo makes you feel
like you need to know everything and
everything in
depth if we look uh at what is generally
called a generalist it will be somebody
that has a good understanding on several
topics but doesn't explore any of those
in really in the big dep then you have a
specialist specialist is a person that
is laser focused on on a specific skill
set on a specific uh set of tools and it
really goes in depth in it and then we
have the t-shape this is really um
really well talked about you can read uh
several posts about it like the one that
I'm l in the bottom and It generally
goes like you acquire a certain amount
of knowledge that is uh spread in the
subject let's say that we are talking
about data related subjects no you know
you learn a bit of SQL you know a bit of
python you know the basics of uh machine
learning with psych learn and then
what um I strongly recommend U when I
talk with people in the early career to
start develop their skills as a team so
you already know
uh several different subjects now try to
go in depth on one why do I make this
advice to to early stage
people honestly early stage people the
fal scenario is completely impossible I
mean the formal scenario is impossible
for everybody for anybody that's a
entire team is not a person and the
specialist is generally not uh an early
um career person I mean that's literally
the definition somebody that is starting
is not a specialist so we are left with
the
journalist and in my person personal
perspective when you are interviewing
people for jobs and you have a
generalist with you know a wide very
wide horizontal bar and you let's say
are hiring for a job that you have in
Time series and then a person with a t
t-shape um experience appears that maybe
he even uh the the t-ship person even
has like a smaller horizontal bar but it
has a bump in the vertical one and if
you are looking for that skill the
t-shaped person will probably win every
time against the generalist of course
and generalizing but in in theory this
should be the way to go so uh I strongly
advise people in their early career to
do uh to try to develop their career
their knoow in the tissue
going in depth in a in a certain topic
let's say now I want to get really good
into developing Python scripts like
writing python reading python is really
important to me so for a couple of
months I will focus only on that and
then when you are satisfied with that
you can move to a different T so your t
uh is not only a t you can have several
T together and then you go let's say
okay I already uh study python so I'm
going to study machine learning and the
math between machine learning and now
you start develop another vertical bar
for another te with this focus and in
the end of the day you the idea is to
develop your career in a way that you
have this horizontal bar ever increasing
but several vertical
bars and that's pretty much my my advice
for for a student like the the this
Eugene our engineering student and um of
course uh also focus on internally
objectives what Eugene would like to
develop and not just focusing on
externally what I saw in the post what I
saw in the video Whatever got most likes
okay it's okay to try things but really
focus on things that you generally like
because it's easier and and uh it will
generate less less
friction so uh now I'm pretty much on
time uh I I wanted to go in the in the
skills exercise let me just look at the
shot if there's something I don't think
there is um
so um what I would like to to show now
is this exercise which is basically a
questionnaire the way this questionnaire
was was design simple seven
questions is to have this with you in
your first steps in the career when you
are finishing as a student and not
feeling it once and leaving it be but
feeling it once and then six months
later come back to here to these
questions fill them again and compare
why in order to create you um a
possibility of looking at things of
seeing your own
Improvement written down because wrting
WR writing things down is very powerful
and helps a lot visualizing visualizing
them so what I have in mind for
this uh I'm going to show you my my
seven answers to this um and then just
give you an idea of what I expect to be
answered for this and then I will like
to ask you to to the participants to to
just um you know uh try to answer um
this
themselves and um if you like of course
um we'll be be very glad to hear your
answers uh to share your answers with us
uh and even maybe discuss them a bit um
and uh if you are if you don't want to
to share them it's completely fine I
just take the the document on yourself
feel it on yourself and by yourself and
then um uh you can always compare uh the
future self with the past
s so going into to to my own answers and
again please feel free to to interrupt
me if you want how many projects have I
made it so far this is a tricky question
right because looking back into college
times is not necessarily you are not
necessarily always the the main person
responsible for a project I put 20 plus
because when I was was in Academia I
really I really did a lot of projects
that I was the the sole responsible and
I had to manage them and in my recent
years uh in the company that I've been
working on um I also did quite a lot of
ownership of projects so I put 20 plus
maybe I'm being a bit too too generous
with myself but I I think it's around
the ballpark of what I manage so looking
at this and trying to be as honest as I
can with myself I can see that who it's
it's actually a big number I was not
expecting it uh to be that big but the
most importantly most importantly for me
is that if I look like one year back two
year back uh I won like several uh
projects uh maybe two years
back I maybe doubl the amount of
products that I manag and that's awesome
to look back and and see that that uh
I'm I developed that skill but I'm still
working on that
skill so regarding presentations again
communication is really really really
important you saw from the the the slide
that Camila shared with us and from what
I talked before like being able to
convey um your uh ideas your knowledge
is super important people may call it
you know soft skills the capacity to
communicate
but honestly if you are in the data job
or the data job market communication is
not a soft skill at all it's part of the
job 100% I put 50 plus here it's like
honestly when I was in the PHD I was
doing like so many presentations that I
think that I'm probably underestimating
it but yeah the most important part of
this is the the second question like the
percentage of those present presents
when I was the the expert in the room
this is really
interesting sorry uh I think that that's
the very interesting question which we
have on the chat and think that can help
with the discussion so uh could you tell
more about the projects which which you
perform what kind of projects were that
oh yeah thank you very much I didn't see
that at all sorry um yeah um personal
projects or professional
projects I'm counting here um again this
is designed before people in the early
stage career so I'm counting stuff like
um um College stuff of course if it was
like very small project not but if it's
like uh you know stuff that I did in my
master thesis stuff that I did in my PhD
like all those uh projects within the
Theses thems I'm counting them in and
then of course I'm accounting as well
pro professional projects stuff that I
did on my own like to to increase my CV
and also stuff that I did in my actual
job hopefully that answer the questions
and my apologies for not not seeing it
before so I was in question 2B I believe
um yeah this is most important part or
the most interesting part of question
two the percentage of those
presentations when I was the expert in
room this is uh something that I really
like to convey to people starting their
career in a data related field you are
going to be the data expert in the
majority of the meetings that you're
going to be
in Period sure um you could to have a
manager and colleagues that work with
you and that are more experienced than
you but as soon as you know in a in your
day job you start to develop projects
and start getting some
experience in the majority of the calls
you're going to be the expert you're
going to be the data person in that call
and here I'm I put 50 uh% plus because
again Academia you generally when you
are in the Academia you're generally not
the expert in the room but after
that um really uh I would like to
challenge people that are listening to
this to really think about who when
you're doing a presentation if you are
not the the expert in the room the data
expert in in the room and this is really
a mind um blowing experience because
then you realize that the way that you
need to convey your ideas the way that
you need to explain stuff it's
completely different because if you are
the one that knows the most about that
subject in in the meeting all the people
um need to to understand the the message
in simpler terms in in simplified terms
so it's really a mind uh
changing experience so when you touch in
this question really uh think about
it oh
sorry so uh the third question is what
CES me so um uh this is uh uh this is
really interesting and important for me
because um again as I mentioned before
in the case of Eugene the engineering
student formo is it's it's really bad
for for you in terms of the stress that
you creates but more
importantly people don't make really
good decisions when they are on the on
the sentiment on the mindset like
fear and what uh this question is here
for is to make you the listener think
about about what causes you for or what
may cause uh in the future or what
causes right now for me it's 100% like
scroll scrolling on social media like
Thinkin any other and seeing people
achievements it looks like everybody's
an expert in every single thing and it's
it's it's really um stress inducing but
at the same time I need to to stop and
think like
okay the that person really develop that
skill or it's showcasing a skill that
you develop is not like I don't need to
do it just because an external Factor
just because somebody in my community or
in my my connections is is doing it as
well I should be focused again as I
talked for the case of hugene in more
intrinsic values and objectives and not
necessarily on on uh on external values
or external ideas so that's why this
question is here so we can identify
where the fomo where the external
pressure come comes
from and then this is really the part
about the skills um as we talked before
mainly mainly for the exercise of Bob
the the molecular biology student
um and a bit t on your genene when we
talked about the t uh T shape so what
are your skills and here please uh in
question 4 a really try to be as
specific as possible like okay I'm able
to read and write um python but
specifically what pandas I'm I'm really
trying to get better aanda so I'm now
succeeding with that uh I'm also now
able to do documentation in Python
script so this the type of of of
specificity that I'm looking for is not
not like oh python I can write python no
no what can you do with python and uh
for instance how have here like Version
Control of Python Programming of python
programs like using GitHub and and stuff
like that again trying to be as specific
as you can because if you use this
document as I intended it to the purpose
is in a year from now we're going to
back to look back at this or six months
from now from now we're going to look
back at this and see oh yeah this is
when I developed that skill and now I've
been using that skill pretty much every
day or every other day or something like
that so again another example with unit
tests and statistics for instance the
topic of Statistics is really difficult
for me at least to go into dep of what
do I really know about statistics but
even so I try to my best to go into
being
specific and then the second part of the
question
uh those generalist skills that I would
like to have and P spark uh spark in
general is one of the things that I that
I would like to but please notice that
in this example here in spark I really
don't know what I don't know so it's
hard for me to put in the pooling points
and be very specific what I would like
to learn so what I did was to uh write
doing a project from top to bottom in
spark so an entire project in spark I
really would like to to do that
why
yes I guess it was nothing um why uh
because I really think that is an
awesome technology and I think it will
benefit me in in work uh honestly these
days you don't see many topics in like
social media about spark but it's still
the technology that I want to develop
the most because I think it's really
useful so uh the final question is um
what would you like to specialize in so
again the t-shape uh we were talking
about the horizontal bar the general
General skills and now things that you
really would like to to do a de Ty so
develop the vertical line and honestly I
played a bit with llms with all this F
that has been about it and I enjoyed it
so I have fun with it so I will really
like to to spend a lot of time in it and
specialize in it and here are some again
very specific objectives that I have
with
it so the way that I planned this it was
now to give you uh attendees some
minutes to to to write this on your own
um actually I should share with
you the link of the document which I
think is this one
apologies
here it
is so this is the link for the the
document is a a Word document in Google
Drive um please feel free to download it
uh and then um edit it in the tool that
you may want apologies for not sharing
it earlier I completely
forgot uh so what I would like to
propose here is is um we do a 10 minutes
break uh you guys have access to the
document download it uh you can even
download it like reach text and then
edit it in the notepad or something the
idea here is not really doing the
exercise for doing is to think about
every uh single one of the of the
answers okay and then I'll suggest in 10
minutes so at uh
18 55 in my time so in 10 minutes from
now at 55 uh we come back and if people
are have stuff to share great we talk
about it if nobody feels like sharing um
great as well um and we close up this
this this session um thank you very much
for for you all that shared and for you
all that were here um really thank you
for being here um please please give me
some feedback the best way to talk to me
it's in the LinkedIn the link in is in
the platform is also in this
presentation here just shut me out a
message tell me that you came from from
here so I can recognize you immediately
and a big thank you to to Camila um I
was not
easier the easiest speaker to get uh so
thank you very much for pushing me and
and to insist and to to make this this
this talk happen because otherwise if it
was not you it will not happen and of
course thank you thank you p uh and
that's it on my
side thank you so much Pedro it was a
great Workshop uh I very happy that it
was very interactive also thank you so
uh so much for uh like make this
Workshop interactive so thank you for
you for all the participants um One
technical thing U because uh you were
sharing uh some private information here
uh about about your um your experience
and and so on so uh as you know this
this worship is recorded but um but uh
we will just cut this part of the of the
workshop so just make that more
comfortable and um yeah and other than
that this first part which was the
presentation you will be able to find
that um in Pay data Global uh channels
perhaps we'll we'll post that on YouTube
yeah thank you so much I believe that we
all learn a lot today so once again P
very much thank you for for for this uh
for this workship and congrats on your
uh all all development because uh
clearly with this Workshop you presented
that uh you are very uh aware of your uh
of your development and you are going in
amazing path so congrats to
you thank you very much everybody thank
you very much camil